A war has been going on for billions of years
that breeds well armed monsters, who struggle with
other monsters for survival. Having no particular
interest in us, most of them are relatively
harmless, as our immune systems deal with
their weapons easily. But there are exceptions.
Naegleria fowleri is an amoeba
that has not only developed a
deadly taste for human brains but is also a
match for our defences and stars in dramatic
headlines. What happens when
this monster enters your body?
Naegleria fowleri is an amoeba, a microbe with a
nucleus, one of the smallest lifeforms on earth.
It is a voracious hunter of bacteria and other
critters that it devours whole and rips into
pieces. Like many amoebea it is able to transform
into different stages that help it survive,
but most of the time Naegleria
fowleri is in its trophozoite stage,
during which it looks like a squishy blob
with tiny arms and hunts, divides and thrives.
Its natural home is in fresh water: ponds,
rivers, lakes and hot springs. But unfortunately
it also feels happy in pipes, swimming pools,
fountains or spas when they are not properly
treated. The warmer the water, the more it thrives
and multiplies. So in the summer, when humans seek
to cool off and enjoy themselves, the chances
are highest that both species will interact.
Because this makes it hard to avoid, millions of
people regularly have contact with the amoeba,
especially in warmer climates, and many people
even seem to have antibodies against it.
And this is mostly ok, you can even
swallow it without consequences.
Things turn bad when people dive or swim in water
contaminated with the amoeba and water splashes
high up into their noses. In a single drop
of lake water there are millions of viruses,
bacteria and amoebea and that isn’t really a big
deal. But Naegleria fowleri is different. Let
us zoom into the nose of an unsuspecting victim
enjoying a great summer day and see what happens.
First of all, the amoeba doesn’t
really want to be inside your nose
as it is not really looking for trouble,
it just wants to eat a few bacteria.
Instead it is greeted by your natural defenses.
Unfortunately for humans, Naegleria fowleri
happens to be exceptionally good at generally
flying under the radar of your immune system.
For example, the inside of your nose is covered
by mucosa, a slime filled with chemicals that
kill or stun possible invaders or alert immune
cells. But Naegleria fowleri is not particularly
bothered by them and instead calmly checks out the
scenery, mildly annoyed about the whole ordeal.
Now, if you are unlucky, the tiny
critter stumbles over something
that actually sparks its interest: Nerve cells.
Your nose is filled with a large
network of olfactory nerve cells
that pick up molecules from the outside and
transmit their information to your olfactory bulb,
the center of smell in your brain. To do
their job these cells talk to each other by
releasing various messenger chemicals and
recognizing them via specific receptors.
One of the most important of
these chemicals is acetylcholine.
Through sheer evolutionary bad
luck, Naegleria fowleri happens to
have receptors that recognize acetylcholine.
And it seems to attract them irresistibly, a
little like moths that are attracted by light.
So as your olfactory nerve cells do their job,
using plenty of acetylcholine to talk to the
brain, Naegleria fowleri enters your tissue. It
seems to follow the chemical signals upstream.
Neutrophils, crazy suicide warriors begin to
attack the amoebae. Individually they have no
chance against them as the invaders are large and
pretty buff fighters, used to dealing with tough
enemies. So the defenders swarm the intruders
and kill them either by vomiting chemicals
that punch holes into them or by literally
ripping parts of them off and devouring them.
But the Naegleria fowleri train is still on track
and while the Neutrophil attacks slow them down,
they continue to follow the olfactory
nerves to their final destination:
Your brain.
This process can take between one and nine days
and you’ll probably not notice
anything during that time.
Until the amoebae reach the olfactory bulb, the
center of smell and entrance to your brain. Your
brain cells are nothing more than helpless victims
and they all release that wonderful acetylcholine.
Naegleria fowleri initiates a massacre and
releases an onslaught of various attack molecules.
Some of them are basically little bombs
that rip holes into your cells on contact
so their pieces can be eagerly
consumed. But Naegleria fowleri
is now multiplying - and it's also becoming
really creepy. In a feeding frenzy it can
develop up to a dozen suckers called food cups,
that look like giant eerie mouths. The amoebae
engage your brain cells, suck them in and
rip large “bites” out of them while they
are still alive. Now things escalate quickly
and the disease that will kill you sets in.
Alerted by the massacre, millions
of immune cells, Neutrophils,
Eosinophils and microglias invade the
infected tissue. Which is a problem:
your immune system is dangerous and not
exactly a careful fighter. It's like
burning down a forest to kill the wolves
inside it. A really bad idea in the brain.
They waste no time and attack the amoeba,
using all the weapons available to them,
from chemicals to trying to eat them
alive. Neutrophils explode themselves
to erect barriers spiked with deadly
chemicals. A fierce battle ensues.
Naegleria fowleri can actually fight back,
itself attacking and killing many immune cells.
The immune system now throws everything it has at
the invader but in vain. The complement system,
tiny protein bombs that can kill intruders on
their own, are easily disabled. Antibodies,
usually one of your superweapons, are just
destroyed or swallowed. A high fever that
usually slows enemies down does nothing,
as the amoeba actually thrives in the heat.
All the while the amoebae continue to
multiply, fight and devour your brain cells.
A disastrous chain reaction is taking place.
One major thing your immune cells do when
they fight is to cause inflammation. Which
directs large amounts of fluid from your
bloodstream into the site of an infection.
So as the battle rages on without a clear
winner, more and more fluid enters the brain.
At this point the human will feel
symptoms that quickly escalate.
It all begins pretty vaguely, a headache, fever,
nausea and vomiting. As the battle spreads
rapidly through the brain serious symptoms appear,
from confusion, inability to concentrate
to fatigue, seizures and hallucinations.
The brain swells up massively but can’t expand due
to the bones surrounding it. So it compresses and
disables the brainstem that controls things like
breathing. Usually within a week the patient dies.
Up to 97% of patients infected by the
amoeba share this fate. In almost all cases,
by the time an infection by Naegleria fowleri is
recognized the disastrous battle for the brain
is already so far along that there is almost
nothing to be done. Not only do we currently
not have effective treatments, there are also an
abundance of open questions about how an amoeba
that usually enjoys its life in open water, is
able to overcome our immune system so effectively.
So how worried do you need to be about this
horrifying killer amoeba? Well, not very. While
the Naegleria fowleri is clearly extremely deadly
and the infection truly horrible, there have only
been a few hundred cases in the last few decades.
You are way more likely to drown in a pool than
to get infected. Not only does the amoeba need
to be flushed high up your nose, it also needs
to get a good grip and it also has to make its
way through the first lines of your defences.
Ultimately Naegleria fowleri is neither evil
nor a huge public health risk. But every year
some unlucky people have to deal with it. We still
have so much to learn about it and until we find a
way to treat it, Naegleria fowleri will continue
to be this vague and horrifying thing, hunting
in puddles and lakes and sometimes pools. Usually
for bacteria. And very occasionally, for people.
- Oh hey, who are you?
It is me, your existential dread!
- Uhm, ok.
I'm here to make you question your own
existence and everything you hold dear in life!
- Could you not please.
Tooooooo late, just look at all these amazing
posters FULL of humbling visualisations like the
scale of the universe. LOOK! How huge it is and
how small you are! Look at the education edition,
how it dives deep into the history of evolution or
all these other scientific fields to make you feel
bad for all the stuff you don't know! Or
look at this one, IT GLOWS IN THE DARK!
- But Dread, these do make me feel good
actually! They do fill me with excitement
and awe about how amazing our universe is and
I love learning! And look how pretty they are!
Nooooooooo, I can't persist in
the presence of awe. Graglgrglglg.
If you too want to overcome your existential
dread, make your life beautiful and also support
Kurzgesagt so we can put thousands of hours
into our videos and release them for free,
you can get these and many many
more amazing posters or shirts or
so many more things in our shop. We put as
much care into our products as into our videos,
trying to find something clever or a new angle
that will challenge your perspective while still
teaching you the core aspects. It’s the best
way to support what we do on this channel.